you know, one of the things that you maybe
don't want to say, if you're trying to convince
other people about how cognitively stable
you are is to make a completely outlandish
claim, like doctors who gave me a cognitive
test were shocked at how well I did on it.
That's essentially exactly what Donald Trump
said to Sean Hannity on Fox News the other
night during the same interview in which he
failed to answer the same questions from a
few weeks ago, a second time.
So let's look at the clip and then discuss
it.
He did mean that because he hasn't taken any
cognitive test because he couldn't pass one.
I actually took one when a very recently when
I when I was, you know, the radical left was
saying is, you all there is you all there.
And I proved that was all there because I
stood the test that he should take the same
exact tests.
The very standard tests I took took it at
Walter Reed Medical Center in front of doctors.
And they were very surprised.
They said that's an unbelievable thing.
Rarely does anybody do what you just did.
But he should take that same test.
But now he has been totally taken over.
Is the constant bragging about really odd
things wearing anybody else down?
And there's a lot to break down here.
But as usual, aside from from Trump lying
all the time, when Trump goes hyperbolic,
you can be extra sure that he's lying.
Doctors were surprised.
Rarely does anybody do what I did on a cognitive
test.
White and the whole context of this is that
the right is trying to frame Joe Biden as
having dementia.
We on the left have had concerns about Trump's
cognitive state for years, and we don't know
whether it's related to cognitive decline
in the form of early stage Alzheimer's or
dementia, side effect of some prescription
medication, drug use.
There's a lot of many, many different ideas
going on.
And there's many examples that point to this.
The verbal glitches that coincide with the
shoulder spasms, Trump not recognizing Rudy
Giuliani when Giuliani was right in front
of them from talking about the oranges of
an investigation.
Trump getting off of Air Force One in front
of his car and wandering off and having to
be brought back by a Secret Service agent
from having to be helped down the ramp after
his West Point speech.
Dozens and dozens of these.
And what they're doing is try to turn trying
to turn it back on.
Biden saying Biden sounds lost.
He doesn't know where he is.
He's hiding from the campaign trail in his
basement because of cognitive decline.
Biden recently said, I'm fine and I've been
tested.
They reacted by saying, why would Biden be
tested for cognition?
And yet now Trump is saying, I've been tested
and I did incredibly well on my cognitive
test.
He even was given a lollipop on the way out
and was able to get a second scoop of ice
cream that night.
What test is he referring to?
First of all, we don't know if Trump is referring
to the Montreal cognitive assessment.
As far as we know, he got that test a couple
of years ago.
This is a simple test.
Thirty point test that takes 10 minutes.
It's really only good for identifying very
serious issues with basic memory, recall and
executive function and just being oriented
in time and place.
So the 30 points come from, for example, the
clock drawing task.
You get three points, I would say to you,
draw a clock and show me what the hands look
like when it's 615, that you get three points
for that copy.
Not even draw from memory.
Copy a three dimensional cube.
That's a point I would ask you.
Where are we right now and what's today's
date?
That's 20 percent of the score.
You have to identify three animals.
OK, so if that's the test Trump is referring
to.
He took it a long time ago and it doesn't
really tell us very much.
Claiming to have aced it is like saying, you
know, I aced a colon.
Ask AP.
Right.
Like these are screening tools for serious
cognitive decline and it wouldn't rule out
any of what's being explored with Donald Trump.
Now, to go back to I took it recently at Walter
Reed.
That's actually a part of this that's not
being discussed as far as we've been informed.
Trump hasn't gone to Walter Reed for medical
evaluation.
He was there recently, I think, visiting troops.
But he hasn't been to Walter Reed for medical
care since that day last year when he was
weirdly rushed there.
And Walter Reed said we didn't know he was
coming.
And what we were told was, oh, he had a.
Two hours free.
And we decided to go and get him a jump on
his 20-20 physical.
It wasn't believable then.
But as far as we know, that's the light.
Last time Trump was there and as far as we
know, he didn't get the Montreal cognitive
assessment that day.
It was actually back in 2018 or even 2017.
So none of it makes sense.
None.
It's all very concerning.
And again, doctors have never seen anything
like my results on a cognitive assessment.
It's the hyperbole that immediately signals
that Donald Trump is lying.
Let me know what you think is behind all of
this.
And remember that you can get the David Pakman
show audio podcast for free.
This is available to everybody every day on
whichever is your favorite podcasting platform
if you use the iPhone podcast's app.
Beautiful.
If you're on your desktop computer and you
like Spotify.
Perfect.
It's available everywhere.
Make sure you're subscribed for free to the
daily podcast to get the full show every day
right around 3:00 p.m. Eastern.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.